how you doing hey sam you are good how
are you
what's up my friend you will
yeah andrew tonks good to good good to
connect
yeah no likewise yeah i don't think i've
actually met you before
seen a lot of you obviously but never
met great stuff well listen man
thanks for your time i just thought um
it'd be great to ask you a few questions
about property what you've been up to
and uh we'll record it i'll send you a
copy
and it hopefully will inspire some
people yeah perfect
cool so what's your background you've
been in the military and stuff
yeah so um i was in the military well
went
school university all the normal stuff
then did 10 years in the military
i was flying helicopters there which is
a pretty cool job to be honest i saw
that on you on your instagram it says
pilot and i was like
interesting yeah well i try and link
those together you know you know all
about doing brands and stuff so i sort
of think you know property pilot linking
together
yeah maybe 10 years doing that which is
great fun
and spent a lot of time in afghanistan
which was a bit interesting some tough
times
yeah yeah yeah but the good thing about
that is that we used to get we go there
for like three or four months at a time
and come back with a big wad of cash in
your pocket because you'd only spent
about 50 pounds
over three months um and most of my
mates were buying secondhand porsches
going on first class holidays and i
basically started doing a bit of
property
by accident basically which is quite
good um so i did that for three or four
years
started building up a small portfolio
and then i was leaving the military and
thought right i bet it's property
seriously because
i might not be able to get another
flying job um you know so actually
should have a good backup in case um so
then basically
the last three years i've been expanding
the property business
and it's yeah it's really taken off the
last uh sort of year or so it's been
great
yeah that's awesome so what so so up
until kind of a year ago
you'd been just a traditional buy to let
investor and you'd built up a portfolio
with your own money right yeah so pretty
much
that was up until about three years ago
i'd say and then the previous two years
before the last year
i was building up nicely but you know
made a few mistakes as people do
yeah they're all rectified now
thankfully which is good
um but yeah it was i went for buy to
let's and then
moved on to some hmos rent to rents you
know a few more creative things
yeah i've done some deal sourcing in the
past
um but only the last year i've really
focused on that a lot more just because
i'm not really sure why but it's really
it's really kicked off the last sort of
six months to a year which has just been
ridiculous to be honest
yeah okay so what's your portfolio like
what your
what your your why to let portfolio so
buy to let's
i've got well let me think um
we've got 14 bytes in total that
includes one block of five flats
yeah 14 bytes and one hmo owned
and then i've also got and 21 hmo rooms
on a rent to rent as well
fantastic so i'm really interested to
talk to you because you've gone from the
traditional buy to let property owner
and you've built up a healthy portfolio
i mean does that generate decent income
yeah and it does generate good income
which is nice to be honest and it's
worked out well for me
yeah so with your rental with your
rental properties that you own
what kind of cash flow are you getting
off the whole portfolio
um oh god
i never think it that's a good question
i've not been asked that question for a
while
[Music]
um
probably on a on a good month it's
probably
five five nine thousand maybe yeah and
what about an average month
average probably more like four to four
and a half because there's always works
going on yeah yeah yeah
absolutely okay but but for most people
that's a that's a
good solid wage right yeah no no exactly
that yeah
it's and it's coming in from rent from
your portfolio which is awesome
talk to me about the transition from
traditional buy to let because now i
mean i see you now on instagram and
stuff you're doing
like rent to rent deal packaging all
these strategies
that are creative that the stuff that i
teach i know you're a fan of my youtube
and stuff and watch a lot of the videos
awesome but like talk to me about that
transition
um well it's a funny one because
most people just tend to do the boring
bite don't they and it's not boring i
love it i want to keep getting more
because they're nice and safe
yeah for me personally i was leaving
military
going to be an airline pilot and you
know as you can see right now being an
airline pilot is a bit of a risky job to
have
so i thought how can i get more cash
flow quickly
you know just you know just in case
things don't go wrong so that's where
i looked at the box of block of flats
because i could buy five and one go
with the same workers buying one but end
up getting more cash flow
yeah so that took a bit of education and
then doing the sort of rent to the hmos
and buying the hmo
again just have to get educated you know
stuff like your videos
books um you know just to make sure that
i was confident because
buying a buy to let now for me is easy
you know if you're buying your first buy
athletics hard but i thought that buying
my first hmo
or rent to rent hmo actually it's a
completely different ball game so i
wanted to make sure that i was
set up you know the right way with all
the compliance and
all the documents that i was needed um
so it was a bit a bit interesting but
i then i think maybe the military
training sort of made me prepared for it
almost
just because you know i knew that
actually it might be a bit scary
but often if you do something scary you
get good reward out of it you know you
talk about that a lot as well
yeah yeah so how many deals are you
packaging and selling them these days
what's going on on that side of things
um at the moment
well i was aiming to do one a week this
year
yeah but i think now i had to look the
other day
i think this year we've done actually
because we had two complete yesterday
i think we've already done about 30 this
year wow that's good
that's serious and and what kind of what
kind of amount are you charging on
average per deal that you're selling
so the lowest i've charged and i'm quite
embarrassed by this
was 400 pounds however that was helping
the mate out and we got a bit screwed
over
but this is a good tip that then
resulted in me
helping that mate sell another five or
six which we've got a lot more money for
yeah it was quite good what's an average
fee
average fee now i'd probably say is
somewhere between two and a half and
three thousand pounds
so if you've done 30 i'm just doing the
math you're talking what like 75 80
grand
this year something like that again and
the one that we completed on yesterday
which was
two hmo plos or lease option agreements
uh that one is that's 9 000
for the one that we sold yesterday wow
nine thousand pound for one thing
yeah i mean that's that's that's the
best one i've done individually so far
but it was yeah yes what was it what was
the what was the deal
it was two um hmos and lease option
assignments for five years
like fully licensed partially talented
um
and yeah you know the investor was happy
i thought about taking on myself
actually but it was just about my area
listen your story is interesting because
without the
without the pile of stuff and without
the afghanistan stuff
your story is kind of similar to my
story because
because i built up a portfolio now i
didn't do it with my own money i
joined venture and use other people's
money and stuff but i built up a
portfolio quite traditionally
combination of hmos single let's and
then i got to the point where i thought
how can i get more money fast like i
just want some fast
quick because making you you're talking
about five grand a month from you from
your buy to let's that's okay
that's good but if you want to get fast
money and you want to make a lot more i
thought
how can i do that and that's when i
asked what across deal sourcing i didn't
know deal sourcing was a thing no one
taught me deal sourcing i just kind of
you know just kind of figured it um and
because of my experience in buy to let's
and stuff
i started packaging and selling deals
like you started killing it with that
then got into other creative strategies
and then used that money that i was
making
to invest into my portfolio started
doing bigger deals
and then and grew that way so that's
kind of my story
um interesting well that we've not met
before because
like normally when i get people on my
youtube channel they're part of my
academy
or i've i've met with them i've seen a
lot of the videos yeah yeah i've
trained them whereas with you we've not
met before so
so talk to me about that
what about why we've not met or yeah why
have we not met
um you've never come to an event you've
never paid me a penny
you've never done any training with me
yeah i mean
i think i signed to one of your events
in the past but couldn't go i mean one
good thing one thing one at one reason
actually
is before the lockdown i spent the whole
winter in australia
new zealand yeah my wife's had a baby so
i took a bit of time off flying
to do that so that's probably one reason
why i'm not seeing you this year
um before that i don't know i've signed
up to events for just stuff got in the
way you know what life is like and with
the fl
i still do fly and that gets in the way
a lot as well yeah i mean the thing is
here's an interesting one andrea and i'm
interested in your opinion on this
because i mean hey i'm not i'm not i'm
not saying why
as in you should have and it's terrible
i'm just
i'm just curious because i know you've
been watching how long have you been
watching my um stuff my free content
online
um over a year i've read your book as
well how much has that helped you with
what you're doing
with the deal sourcing and all that so
it's been it's been very helpful
and you know one of the things i say
actually i had my baby last september
yeah congrats thanks very much i know
you're a family man as well
but during the autumn last year you know
and this is god's honest truth
so the three four am feeds you know put
on youtube
sing on a couple of samuel lee's videos
and you know just for a bit of
you know well entertainment and a bit of
education at the same time
yeah i found they needed something to
keep me awake enough
where some traditional videos maybe
aren't quite as you know entertaining
so you know with a nice mix here's the
discussion
kind of the thing that i want to talk
about which is interesting because a lot
of people ask me the question they say
you know why do i need to pay for
training when i can when i can just do
your online stuff because i put out a
lot for free
my life and people sometimes say you're
too expensive i'm having joe lycip right
now
um on on channel four you know taking
the mickey said i'm really expensive i
i have a lot of people saying that my
customers don't say that ironically
you know nearly all of my customers the
statistics are over the moon love the
training but the people
on the outskirts are looking at that's
expensive and then try and take the
mickey
and my argument and i'd love to know
what you think of someone that hasn't
paid me a penalty my argument is listen
i want every single person to be able to
benefit from my training so i'm going to
do my books
my crash courses i'm going to do as my
all my youtube videos every day for free
i'm going to then if you want a bit of
mentoring a bit of coaching we've got
samuel 365 which is 95 pound a month
and then if you want to go the full hog
and you want to do all my courses and
all my training my most
if you do everything together it's 12
000 pounds and that's for people that
want to do
want to do it now i think that there's
value in that if you're starting out and
you want to go from zero to 100
and you want to figure everything you
want to learn everything and
for you when you stumbled across me
you'd already built up a large portfolio
so you had a lot of that foundational
stuff
so then transitioning into deal sourcing
for you
isn't such a big deal because it's like
well i've done it myself for the last
x number of years so i just think it
depends on the person for some people
some most people wouldn't be able to do
what you've done and just
start deal sourcing and make 75 grand so
far within five months
with no proper training i don't think
that's feasible for most people i think
most people would need some advanced
training somebody
yeah right but like i don't know what do
you think about the whole debate and the
whole topic as someone that's benefited
from my free training that's never
actually paid me
what's your response to these joe life
characters well my my
my thought would be that it depends on
the person purely
um i think for me personally because
maybe on my military background
i've always been a bit of a go-getter
you know probably like yourself um
so i'll you know suck up information and
i'm i'm not afraid to take a jump
and go go for a bit of a risk yeah maybe
that's because i've got the previous
portfolio or you know my flying job um
but i think because it because you put
out so much information there's actually
enough stuff to get you started there
and then i fell back on my previous
experience
um and that might work work for some
people i think others you know often you
can get all the free information but to
actually take the leap because it's
scary
yeah actually i think the officer may
need your hand held
or you know if you know having your hand
held isn't enough maybe a bit more
guidance actually someone you know
mentoring you
you know like you offer to um sort of
help them properly through the process
to get started and then they can
continue to build on
build on that but i think it just
depends on the person you know how
dedicated they are how motivated
and how much experience they've got and
you know
how much how much work they're putting
willing to put in as well because i
think that's probably the main thing
yeah and
it's really it's an interesting
discussion and i appreciate your
feedback on it
like i pay my personal trainer to come
around my house every day and train me
now the only reason i pay him for
for him is for accountability because i
don't know if he doesn't come around my
house
i'm not doing push-ups
you know so i pay him i pay him a good
salary and that's just for
accountability so i feel
with my i know you've not done my
advanced training so it'd be hard to say
but with my training
accountability and people say oh it's
all online for free
everything's online for free yeah okay
there's no point for harvard university
there's no point for anything what why
be why go
learn to be a doctor because you can
find it for free but there's so much
crap online
filtering through it filtering through
the crap
i'm just like you know what now forget
that i'm gonna go to a proper trainer
that's actually done it
have you done any training yeah i have
done some but that was
uh 2017 i did some here how much do you
spend
um on that i spend it's about 15 000
pounds
obviously you have done training yes i
did some back then yeah but there wasn't
really
any specific deal source and training in
there well the thing is though when
i think when you are a property investor
and when you're making money yourself
being a deal source
is actually kind of easy because it's
just like i know how to find good deals
i'm experienced myself i know how to put
together a power team i know i've talked
to agents now all i have to do is just
figure out how to actually
pass this on to an investor and charge a
fee that bit is basic business sense
yeah yeah it's basically just you know a
little bit on the side
yeah then you can do what you've done in
the past what i've done and actually
make it more than a bit on the side
yeah and when you focus on it it does
you know end up becoming more than that
because you can make a profit from it
what been the biggest mistakes that
you've made over the last however many
years you've been
you've been investing in and doing
property
um biggest mistakes
uh i've jumped into deals before where
maybe i didn't do quite enough due
diligence
yeah and they've thankfully worked that
all right but just been a lot more work
yeah i'd say that and i'd also say that
probably not asking
not asking for help enough because i'm
i'm a bit of a proud person out to the
military
i don't know it phones me personally but
um
i think if you're struggling with
something if you ask for help from
someone more experienced
or someone who's just done it before
then actually that is
that's a real a real real powerful thing
it can help you out a lot probably save
you a lot of money as well
that's a really good point i think one
of the big advantages that i had when i
started was i was so young
i was unashamed to just say i don't know
what to do yeah i'm just kidding
yeah i'm a teenager i've not got a
history of of
you know family generational property
investors i'm starting out
so i'm all right to just be like i don't
know what to do i'm right to say what
does that mean
but i feel that pride can actually
really
actually really hinder you so that's an
interesting point yeah and there's no
no such thing as a stupid question
either yeah
yeah what's your goals over the next
sort of six months of the year
um so looking to continue the deal
packaging
uh but that's basically fun more for
more properties but i'd like to double
the size of the portfolio i think
yeah where are your houses where are
they based
on manchester or greater manchester
which is where i'm from even
london um so i think yeah doubling the
portfolio with either purchases
purchases or lease options is is the
main name really
um that's good that's really interesting
so
what's been the biggest kind of learning
point then if you if you were speaking
to your younger self that was just
starting out in property what would
what were the biggest tip you could give
i would say biggest tip
build up the cash flow first of all
because without the cash flow you can be
looking around for big deals or index if
you've not got the cash flow
you know be it from deal sourcing some
rent to rents
or some other nice deals that actually
you know you could be doing big deals or
whatever but because you've not got the
cash flow you go bust
and you've got that's so true and talk
to me about the difference between for
anyone that doesn't understand for the
difference between
cash and cash flow so savings because
when you say oh building up cash flows
some people think in their mind that
means
saving up money flow is a different
thing what's the difference
yeah so well cash is just money you've
just got sit there it's not earning any
profit or any interest on it anything
like that whereas cash flow is
regular money coming in each month each
month it's almost like the blood running
through your veins
comes in every month it keeps it ticking
over yeah
yeah and you know what's really
interesting as well i think that no
matter what happens to the property
market
people say what's going to happen to
houses you know it's looking like
they're going to go down
but what's going to happen and
ultimately if you've got properties that
are giving you good cash flow whether
they go up whether they go down it
actually doesn't matter that much
no exactly you know you buy because flow
instead of instead of
i'm hoping for capital appreciation
listen capitalization doesn't pay the
bills
no exactly you know i buy buy for cash
flow and then capital appreciation is a
bonus
i think so i think so and and there's so
many investors right now that are
freaking out because they think the
property prices are going to go down
this year
my attitude is it doesn't matter if they
go down as long as because the rents
aren't going to go down
they're going to they might they may
even go up i think they will go up
and hmos particularly i mean you know
you're buying hmos and stuff
i think that as people struggle and as
people lose jobs
they're going to be forced to have to
downsize into hmos and i think hmos are
actually going to become very very
popular in demand over the next couple
years
yeah and i think you're right on that
one yeah so what's been what
what would you advise best strategy then
if you're starting out like you started
very um
traditionally you also were fortunate
you were able to have
uh income you had a good income from
your from working in afghanistan which
got you kind of got you started in
property but if you're starting out from
scratch and you've got no money
whatsoever
like i mean i t you know me you know my
training i'm like
i started with nothing at 17 and i don't
teach the slow
10 year plan i teach actually you know
what if you put the effort in
you can get started quickly even if
you've got very little money i mean what
would be your advice to someone starting
now what do you think
uh starting now i think the best and
it's a perfect time for it the best
thing to do would be
to focus on lease options and rent to
rent
via hmos or maybe later in the year
service accommodation
and get some of them because you get the
good cash flow um
and especially if you get the lease
options then you can be building up your
long-term portfolio as well
yeah and what any deals that don't suit
you sell them on
because then you'll be able to get
enough money to to fund the next deal as
well
yeah and most people don't understand
lease options and rent to rent like
it's absolutely and some people that
don't understand them i see i see people
even in like um in the comments and
stuff on youtube saying oh you know
that's a scam that's not legit and it's
like listen
don't talk about something that you
don't understand because to say that
if anyone that tells me lease options
are a scam or that or they're not legit
it's clearly someone speaking out of
ignorance that just hasn't done it
yeah i mean they broad they're really
common in um
commercial property as well they've been
around for a long time it's just that in
residential
they're not as popular not as popular
but i think they will be now yeah i mean
unless you're in scotland if you're in
scotland
different different story but but but
the rest of the uk
so what is a lease option so it's a um
lease option agreement or purchase lease
option it's where you agree
a um a set purchase price with the
vendor say in
three five or seven years time and then
in the interim
you will pay them a lease fee monthly or
however
however you agree to to service you know
their mortgage debt they've got it or
just to pay them a little bit of profit
and then the way you make it work is
that you turn that into
maybe a hmo or sa or you just
put you maybe do a little bit of a
refurbishment and put in better tenants
yeah you do something to make a bit of
profit on top and then during that five
year period
or at the end of it you'd maybe choose
to buy it yourself maybe renegotiate or
maybe
actually what some people do is agree to
sell it on to somebody else for a
slightly higher price
and then make a bit of capital profit in
between yeah
and it's amazing how long like five
years is because
people people might be thinking oh i
don't want to secure a lease option
agreement now because house buses are
going to go down listen house prices are
probably going to go down yes over the
next year or so quite possibly
but five years is a long time like when
i did some lease option agreements in
2009
and in dozen property prices are
absolutely rocketing in the midlands and
everyone was saying oh
they're gonna crash they're gonna crash
it's like actually they kind of already
have crashed
and then within a year or two they
started shooting up and after five six
years
when i came to complete on my lease
option agreements that some of them had
almost doubled in value
exactly like it's just crazy power
going sorry i'll just say it's crazy how
people's predictions
i know you can be so wildly wrong i
think it's just the fear you know that
fear
often scares people from taking any
action and you know if you're scared of
that i'd say
on any lease options make sure they make
a monthly profit and you get cash flow
going
yeah the capital gain is just a bonus on
top at the end
yeah as as an experienced investor
that's got quite a large portfolio and
has done it
without without my training like you
can't you start watching my videos a
year or so ago and
it might have helped you on the creative
side of the source and whatever
but like is there anything that i teach
is there any strategies which you're
like oh i fancy a go at that but i've
not done it yet or you think
i don't believe that that [ __ ] that's
not legit or anything like that
um i did like i did like your recent
videos about
about um sourcing during lockdown
because i've done a bit of myself but i
thought
god you're a bit bit more confident than
me um because i just
i don't know i mean what i was it's not
it's not really a strategy but i think
for a lot of your videos when you be
like right i'm going to get a deal
today and almost you know set i think
the way you set yourself mini targets
you know it can be for any sort of deal
but i think that is um
that's something i say but in terms of
what you're doing
if you wait if you if you live if you
lived in a purse in a lease option
no i've never lived in one now and i
don't think so that's something i might
look at in the future
but no no i think it's the fact that
you're doing so many different things
it's you know trying to keep up with you
i'm trying just to do a few things at a
time
you know it's about lockdown but you've
killed me dude in lockdown i mean
i mean you you've been out out selling
me with the deal source inside of things
i mean it's not something i really focus
on too much but honestly
you say you've done you've sold 30 deals
so far this year
dude pretty much the whole it's not even
we're not even halfway through the year
and pretty much
the whole of this year has been in
lockdown almost like the corona thing
kicked off
in sort of february march time
march it started things started getting
really difficult april we were locked
down the whole of april
the whole of may so far so i think what
i think you're doing really
seriously when it's also interesting
that people are still buying right now
yeah no because i as soon as coronavirus
kicked and i thought oh that's it game
over
and i had a little moan to myself for a
day or so i thought
this could be this could be bad here but
yeah people are investors looking for
what kind of properties are they looking
to buy
so up until up until last week
they were one in tenanted hmos
or long-term lease options on buy to let
or sa or hmos
whereas this last week people have
started looking again for service
accommodation as well
yeah um and then there's still a few
people looking for land deals but i keep
them separately because they're a bit
the development stuff is a bit more
complicated and a bit more long-term
yeah anything talented and anything
long-term people will go that should be
your next challenge though
andrew big big deals lands development
yeah well that's what that's what i'm
looking at you know now that i've got
the other systems in place i think you
know because you know one big one big
land deal either for myself
or sourcing on you know could be he is
with a pay basically in one deal
my advice generally to people and to be
interested in what you think of this but
maybe this would be my advice to you
even
would be i think start off by a small
small do a small deal
for your first one because number one is
if you haven't got landlord experience
you're gonna stick with the finance
number two is a small deal you're
probably gonna make mistakes on your
first deal it's gonna be
better to make mistakes on a small deal
so do a small bill to begin with maybe a
little single layer then do a slightly
bigger deal
then a slightly bigger deal and every
time you buy a house let it be a bigger
deal
and then and then once you've got five
or six maybe sell those first couple
that you bought
and then put them towards the next
bigger and just get bigger and bigger
and bigger
because because it's just as much effort
to do a big deal is to do a small deal
but you just add an extra zeros on the
end
yeah no agree you know you might you'll
have the same power team involved maybe
you may be playing the architect a bit
more you know project manager a bit more
but actually yeah it's
not much more effort for a lot more
rewarding i think you have to i think
you have to cut your teeth with a small
thing
you know yeah oh yeah with more deals
even with the packaging you have to put
your teeth with just selling
you know a really small essay or buy to
that deal to be honest just so you can
learn the ropes
yeah because also you need to know you
need to know what you're talking about
as well
if you're trying to buy a portfolio or a
big block of flats or something or do a
big development deal
if you go and chat to the agent vendor
you don't and you don't know what you're
talking about they're gonna they're
gonna
kick you out they'll kick you out in a
hurry aren't they um yeah
yeah dude that's awesome i'm really
excited for you i mean what would be
your final words of advice to anyone
watching this that wants to get started
in property or was
interested in doing more being more what
would you say
um so i say two things i'd say
make sure you're educated first of all
either
you know if you can just look at it look
at the free stuff great otherwise get
some education from someone you like
yourself or
or you know a good a good good training
company because without
education i mean i'll take it back to my
job my pilot right
yeah you know that's the fly plane i
don't know how to fire plane
okay i'm sure you can learn for free
still though not a good move
you're gonna have a crash that's
it but so would you jump if i said there
you go samuel here's the keys to my
plane
would you try and give it a go no never
exactly
so that's why you need to get trained
and educated
um so so you do that and then secondly
i'd also say
just be persistent and you know keep on
going because the compound effect
i found in the deal sourcing you know
find it with other strategies
if you keep on going keep on learning
eventually the rewards will come and you
know they'll come
because the problem is i think a lot of
property investors start after a year
they've not achieved anything
but give it two three four five years
and all the guys have been on property
for a long time you know like yourself
they're all doing well because they're
stuck at it and they're compounded
persistent absolute king and also i love
your analogy about the plan
here's my opinion as well i have to say
it because of all this stuff that people
are saying oh you can do it all online
for free
yeah all right do it online for free
then i do it that i put it out
deliberately online for free so that you
can i'm for free
i'm very but the thing is if you take
something really seriously
you're going to pay yeah you wouldn't
you wouldn't
watch youtube videos on learning how to
fly a plane and then go and try and fly
a plane why not because you value it and
you don't want to crash
you really value this and in the same
way if you're going to half ass
property oh you know i'll have a little
go i'll watch a few videos have a little
go then fine but if you want to
really take it seriously get really
serious results and learn properly
then pay and listen i don't care you do
whatever's best for you i i'll give you
both options
but don't have a go at me for char for
charging when you want me to spend time
with you like come on get real
joe license you know how much he charges
is this me so i'm too expensive he
charges 20 000 pounds for a 10 minute
speech
how much value is in that how much value
is in that compared to 10 000 pounds
to learn every single course there is
about property over a 12-month period
it's just like
it's just i can't be different i can't
believe
people's audacity
yeah it's just i don't know i find it
strange because you know having paid for
education you know separate separate
your stuff but i find it if you pay for
something you often value it a lot more
and you're more likely to
to succeed as well because you've paid
for it and you're gonna work hard
yeah yeah yeah sometimes if you've just
got the free stuff you know
what's the value of free stuff yeah you
know some people they don't say it's
valuable at all and
they may not put it anyways actually if
they put a stake in their ground
paid some money you know got some
accountability chances are
they're much more likely to succeed as a
result yeah
for sure for sure dude i appreciate you
bro thank you for your time
keep smashing very much if you think
drop your message on instagram
and uh and don't pay joe likes it twenty
thousand pound for a ten minute speech
because you can watch him
wait i don't even need this i'm not
paying oh dude you can you can watch it
on time you can watch the show but
you'll have a good chuckle it'll be good
fun but you want to get rich then just
stick watching youtube videos of mine
yeah no cool yeah i'll check him out
thanks very much check him out but don't
pay him 20 grand just watch his jokes
are for free online
fine i'll put on some properties instead
yes peace out bro much love
okay see ya